so hello everybody i am here and i know
everybody's excited i'm here with father
stephen de young
the host of the lord of spirits podcast
he is also an orthodox priest
and his new book the religion of the
apostles
has just come out i guess yesterday or
just few days ago and i was i heard that
it is flying off the shelves
and i had a chance to read it i'm one of
the lucky few that had a chance to read
it
uh before and so i'm really looking
forward to having this discussion with
father steven
this is jonathan pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
so father stephen i uh before we got of
get into the to the meat of the book and
also of the lord's spirits
there has been so much discussion around
the symbolic world and
there's this strange confluence well not
strange actually wonderful confluence
of interest between the the different
worlds and so tell us a little bit about
what it is that prompted you to uh to
write this
well this this book is sort of filling a
niche i decided early on that if i was
gonna write things
i wasn't going to write my version of
a thing that already exists right
yes another version
one of the things unfortunately in
english english-speaking orthodoxy is
that we have a very
high concentration of a few things
and then very little of a wide range of
things
i'm only qualified to address certain
little parts of that um
but fortunately some of those little
parts are completely unrepresented now
and so this is
this is one of them uh so the religion
of the apostles
is a bunch of things looked at in
different ways
but one of the main things it is is a
sort of one-volume
orthodox biblical theology yeah which
is a thing that until this hasn't
existed in english
well i think that there it's such an
opportune moment
there's something about the state of
biblical scholarship which you could say
that until
you know until a few decades ago was
quite was quite aggressive and was quite
was used in a way to kind of destroy
christians to destroy their faith
and what i really enjoy about your
approach what i see in the book and also
what you're doing on lord of spirits is
you're flipping the tables
and you're using you know kind of this
second temple
um these second temple theories and
these these new biblic this new biblical
scholarship to
to then point back and to to point back
to
the the uh the liturgy and you know the
sacred space and all of this type of
thinking which
had been discounted by the 19th century
type of scholars
but now is is has there's room for it
again so that's exciting
yeah one of the one of the uh
good elements of what post-modernism has
done
is that it's kind of trashed modernism
[Laughter]
yeah it's made the reason the
rationalist materialist world
insufficient and and and and and so
there's a
crack that's open that we can actually
speak it to
right and so that i the idea i mean it
seems so strange when i tell people this
but the idea that
hey if we go and look at other jewish
writings from the time of the new
testament that could help us interpret
the new testament
it's an idea that did not really exist
in biblical scholarship until the late
70s and early 80s
exactly right but then you realize that
these texts like even though some of the
texts maybe were lost or semi-lost
the contents of the texts were kept in
these medieval traditions
in these kind of medieval legends and so
the content was still there in the
iconography
and so it's as if all of a sudden this
kind of new biblical scholarship
is is shining a light on some of the
elements which were there
but so it's actually supporting the the
kind of liturgical point of view let's
say
right right and and the previous
modernist approach it said
well we need to be skeptical of all that
right
all those any christian writer is lying
right he's not objective and we need to
go back
and we apply these objective laws of
history and make our reconstruction of
what
really so you have all the quests for
the historical jesus stuff and all that
um but then post-modernism says well
there is no objective right yeah we're
at least that the world is bound in
stories and that the world is
is is from a point of view let's say and
so
you know and then with with kind of
cognitive science and these new
these new approaches to emergence and to
attention and all these problems coming
up even in the
in physics you know in terms of the
limits of of uh you know the
relationship between attention and even
uh phenomena all of a sudden this idea
of ritual doesn't become so stupid
anymore
it like really it really becomes
something that that is
that is makes sense even for a secular
person
right and there is always a subject
right that's what subject see we use
objective it's objective in this weird
way
yeah exactly but the real idea is just
that there's a subject
there's an observer it's from someone's
point of view
yeah and that doesn't mean that it's
that it's arbitrary right
and that's that's what people have been
trying to to push is that that
if something is subjective it means it's
arbitrary but that that's not it because
the the the perce human perception has a
pattern
and human communion has a pattern and
all of these things are
are not at all arbitrary because even if
you go down to the most materialist
level
it ends up flipping the tables because
you're like you know if you're going to
apply
materialist rules to to things apply to
everything
and what happens is you have to talk
about consciousness you have to talk
about
you know your experience all of this now
has to flood back into the story
and so it's like a surprise sometimes i
even see it as slightly
akin to the trick that christ plays when
he goes down into hades
where you know the the scientists
thought oh we've dealt with all this
stuff
now we've got we're going to deal with
consciousness and they tried to pull
consciousness down to their material
world
and it did the opposite of what they
thought it would do it actually
shot it actually like was shining light
on the world in a way that they didn't
expect it
flipped it you know yeah yeah thomas
dagel who's
the contemporary great philosopher of
mind
right right now talking about human and
other consciousness
said there's no view from nowhere
right so you you can't write something
you can't describe
something from nowhere right you have to
have a point and so that's
that's really the approach of the book
that's why it's titled what it is
yeah is saint paul the other apostles
right from the perspective of saint paul
and the other apostles
so you they're not writing an abstract
quote
objective treatise about
some unformed reality they're
they're writing from their perspective
from their own conscious experience and
so
the book is trying to approach the
scriptures
from that viewpoint not from our modern
or postmodern perspective
but what was their perspective to
understand what they
wrote from that perspective
but what you do as well like there's a
lot there's a lot of stuff
what i what i sent from the book what i
got from the book let's say is that
it takes what you're doing lord of
spirits but it's not it's as if it ad
there's a lot more than what's happening
in the holy spirit the word of spirits
is like a
section of the book let's say uh but the
the
the rest of the book is really trying to
show also even
in the old testament you know but you
mentioned this in lord of spirits a few
times where
the idea of the monotheism that we
understand today like the kind of
late you know this more modern vision of
monotheism it just wasn't there it was
never there
it's not there in the old testament and
second temple definitely not
and that there really is a sense of
different hypostases already in the old
testament
right yeah well i mean the the term
monotheism doesn't start getting used
until the 16th and 17th century
and that's not because the words didn't
exist monos
were around for the church fathers and
everyone else to use
right and the apostles used if they
wanted to they never did
right and they did use the term
polytheism
to refer to paganism yeah they usually
called what they were doing
monarchianism but
that distinguishes it from what we now
call they actually use that word
monarchicalism really
yeah yeah that's tainted now yeah yeah
it's a wonderful
it's a wonderful world in this set it's
a wonderful word in the sense of
understanding
the hierarchy but it is problematic in
the sense that it can give you the sense
that god is inside the system
um but in terms of just a understanding
an analogy to understand that there is
all this whole stuff happening between
god and us like it's not just god and us
yeah they they meant it at the at the in
the root meaning right that there's one
are he one first principle
yeah okay yeah yeah monarch right yeah
and that's that's principle
right but there are lots of beings yeah
aside from that first principle they
just
aren't separate independent first
principles
right yeah and in a way that i guess
that was why there was so much emphasis
on the idea of uncreated the idea that
there there's a there's a cat there's a
chasm between the uncreated and the
created but the created is
a lot bigger than what you think like it
includes
all of these hierarchies of angels which
are so present in the liturgy
you know once you start to notice it you
realize that they pop up all of these
different little places
even in your prayers like in your daily
prayers you see that there is these
references to uh
to to these hierarchies of beings that
are that are that participate in this
cosmic dance i guess you could call it
yeah
a lot of what we do on lord of spirits
is if
if you're already in the orthodox church
and you're attending the services and
paying attention you have a lot of the
dots
but you don't necessarily know how to
connect them or how they connect to each
other to make a picture
right you can just start drawing lines
but that doesn't always give you
anything
cohesive you know and so kind of what
we're doing is
well here's a few extra dots that you
may not be aware of and now here let's
start
connecting some of these and then people
sort of take off on their own
yeah once they start to see those things
and the picture starts to take shape
and the image i think the image that god
is calling us to participate in the
divine council
the formulation i think is so useful
it's it's so useful for so many reasons
and i think it's going to be useful even
in
speaking to protestants and to people
and
because it's it really can help you
understand like
what these saints are about you know
without that concept you can still get
it but once you have that idea that it
when christ tells us we're going to rule
with him christ says that's
what we're meant to do and so this image
is already there
in the in scripture and if you look at
the iconography
it's in the iconography it's like it's
so crystal clear you look at this image
of the last judgment
and you have christ up there with with
you know with the mother of god and and
and the foreigner and then the apostles
and the angels behind
and so you can just see that if that's
what it is it's obviously a divine a
divine counsel
it it it it is this court that is that
is judging the world with christ
right and it's it's
when when people have an issue with that
it's usually because they're
coming at it from the wrong side
they come at it from the side of well
why do i need anything or anyone but god
right or why would god need anyone but
himself
but that that destroys the whole
concept of christianity and salvation
right
god doesn't need anyone or anything yeah
but
that shares you can really like i always
just bring it back down to the most
i always like to bring things down to
the most common experience and
and i always say okay so why did you ask
me to get that plate then
like why did you just didn't just ask
god like why did you ask me to help you
with your car
like why didn't you just ask god you
know it's it's it's and
and then usually then this argument
would be something like yes but you're
asking for spiritual things and i'm like
really let's talk about that
like like if you if you ask me to help
you because you're not doing well
like what do you think you're asking
you're asking for consolation from me
just get it from god right don't get it
from me uh and so it's
it it as soon as you bring it down to
everyday experience you realize
that it becomes a silly argument you
know like it destroys not only
christianity it destroys the entire
universe like it destroys the world if
you think
that that god didn't actually create all
of this to participate in the way that
he reveals himself and
manifests himself in our life you know
it destroys the world
yeah well yeah yeah and it's this
utilitarian approach
of well i just need god to save me
right because i have this problem which
is i'm worried i might go to the bad
place when i die
and so i have to see but i don't need
anything other than that other than that
i'm good
you know so i could just kind of do my
thing
you know once i get those boxes checked
to get that taken care of
yeah yeah exactly and then i could move
on
it's it's not about need it's about
again it's about love there's sort of a
self-centeredness to utilitarianism
right of i'm only going to interact with
other people the minimum amount i need
to
and i'm only going to interact with god
in the spiritual realm the minimum
amount i need to
for my own benefit you know whereas god
is the opposite of that
god doesn't need any of this it's just
pure love
and sharing of what he has and who he is
yeah and it's overflowing i think that
that's the thing that once you start to
get a sense of what's going on
in in the in the liturgy and in the
orthodox tradition is
there really this kind of overflowing
and and this um
this kind of joy right the joy in bowing
before each other of giving each other
the holy kiss not now but
you know before kobet hopefully after
kobit
uh you know giving each other a kiss
gotta get away with it again sorry
down here we can kind of get away with
it again yeah i know in canada we've got
the gestapo
like uh we we celebrated pasca uh on
sunday morning because we couldn't do it
on saturday night
and uh the police came by three times
drove in front of the building slowed
down
and tried to see what was going on
inside three times
wow i mean can you imagine it's just
scary it's scary stuff
yeah we're kind of through the looking
glass when americans look at canada as a
police state
[Laughter]
yeah we've got we've got we've got
justin we've got uh anyways let's not go
into politics too much
that could go down a slippery slope
pretty fast um
all right and so i have okay i have i
have
some major questions like for myself
because i've been following lord spirits
obviously everybody knows and i've been
really excited
to see how it for me at least how it
connects
a lot of the dots i would say in the
sense that a lot of intuitions i've had
a lot of things that i've noticed on my
own but sometimes i don't have the
information
and so you know you're giving me a lot
of
of tools one of the one of the most
powerful image that you've given me is
the image of
um the idea that the angels of the left
hand right this idea that
that the demons are actually in the end
kind of doing god's will
um because sangre of nisa talks about
that at an individual
scale he says that each person is given
an angel and a demon
and that you know the angel is kind of
carrying you up and the demon is
pulling you down let's say really like
in the cartoons like you see in the
in the with the angel on the on the one
side but the idea that there's a cosmic
that
in the cosmic vision that the fathers
already had this
this notion um is really helpful in
terms of understanding
how reality can work and my big question
this is my big question
so there's a there's an individual level
and there's a cosmic
level but do you think or have you seen
traces that there are
other levels like at other other places
so like an example a simple example
would be let's say you have the angel of
a city
like would there be would there be like
the demon of a city that's pulling
things down let's say i don't know if
you've seen traces of that in the
tradition at all
well yeah i mean the place you most
clearly see that is
for example the roman empire during
christianization
right where uh the city of uh
now thessaloniki right thessalonika
you know had artemis presiding over it
that was a spirit
who was presiding over that city
and is sort of overthrown by
saint demetrius okay yeah in that sense
who becomes the patriots here of that
city uh but that
that didn't mean that all the pagans
just vanished right
there's like there could be like a
haunting of of artemis that could be
for if people continue to worship her in
the city like there could be a there
could still be some tension in the
in the in the city let's say right and
there's a constant
theme in ancient near eastern literature
and even into the
greco-roman period that
there are these demons in like ruined
places
ruined cities and abandoned cities who
are the gods
of that place that now have no
worshipers
right and they're so they're kind of
these residues these
kind of like the titans or these these
the these these beings that are on the
edge and they're kind of falling apart
or
fragmenting let's say and sort of
haunting the pla and they're weak but
because of that they're also
sort of vicious and need to be avoided
and warded off and
you know exorcisms need to be coming
done on the place
you know to to rededicate it so the way
that i'm thinking of it is mostly like
let's say like a modern city
so you think that imagine new york new
york has a pretty strong
presence like it has an effect on the
world it it has a it's pretty
important and so could it be
it would it be possible to imagine that
there's a that there's like a battle
for principality happening in that
for that city let's say right that
there's that there's a battle for the
city
and you've got let's say christians
praying and you've got other things
going on
and so there's this battle for the for
who for which
principality is going to rule over the
the way that the city is going to
to lay itself out that's that's the
that's what i'm wondering about yeah
sorry that's the short answer he says
yes that's the short answer
because yes because if that's true like
that that
i like i basically if i if i can if i
can think that
then i i feel like pretty much my very
much
a large part of reality is going to be
solved for me
yeah well i think
i think the last time we we we talked we
briefly touched on pan psychism i think
for a second
but i think it's even correct to say
that they're battling for the soul of
the city
yeah in a sense
yeah exactly kind of like segregated the
image that he gives of the angel and the
demon
let's say pulling on each side and then
you as the person
uh you know either following your angel
or following your demon
and that will that will direct your your
soul like you said
that'll direct your your your life and
and it'll manifest itself in
in your actions and in everything about
you
right right and we tend to think of
soul as something that just humans have
that's not the way
any ancient or even medieval person
thought of it right animals have souls
area all these things have souls they
just have different types of souls
plants have souls
right but you could go beyond that to
the idea
that a community right
a a town a police right a unit
has a has a shared life yeah well
christ seems to point to that when he
talks about judging cities like when he
says
woe to you you know it'll be worse for
you in the time of judgment than it was
for
for sodom and gomorrah he seems to be
treating the city as a being
that you know that that that has a life
that will be judged as well in the
in the age to come yeah and this
i just reflected in orthodox praxis in
some cases
for example after communism fell
the the russian federation had a long
period of public mourning and repentance
or the death of the czar in his family
the murder of the czar and his family
almost none of them were alive at the
time
the people who were there repenting of
this but it's almost like
there needs to be a kind of yeah there
needs to be a repentance in order to set
things
set things right and to kind of realign
the city you could say towards the good
right right the the the community's life
has to be reoriented
put back in order right justified
yeah and the taint the taint was
actually in the geography
and and this is not quite yeah and it's
not it's not it's like you know you can
even see it's not
superstitious it's like you could
actually measure it almost you could see
that the taint of the killing of the
tsar it manifested itself in the
in the destruction of the the churches
and the the
sacralization of of the land and you
know the desire to not just
it's like because it this idea of
desacralizing it's not just we're going
to get rid of it
if we're going to twist it like we're
going to make it and we're not going to
just destroy the church we'll make it
into a stable we'll
have like feces in it we'll we'll try to
it's a it really is this
this kind of embittered action that is
more than just
a a calculated political move let's say
yeah well
that's because atheism is a myth
not the sense i usually use myth in a
bad sense
in the way they used it i'm not really
existing because every atheist
is dragging around the dead body of the
god he doesn't believe in
yeah behind him right because
a negation can't exist there's there's a
a joke from an old movie that uh slavoy
jishek of all people uses to illustrate
this that a negation can't exist
where a guy is in a restaurant and he
says to the waiter
uh can you bring me a cup of coffee
uh sugar but uh hold the cream
and the waiter comes back a few minutes
later and says i'm sorry sir we don't
have any cream can we hold the milk
instead
that's amazing so
to to have no cream right you have to
have cream
exactly geisha can't exist without the
thing it's negating
no you're i think you're so right that's
something that i've been kind of
pointing to i did a
video on this this like weird kind of on
one division and the montero video like
this kind of weird satanic moment
um and i also did one on the inverted
pentagram
talking about this how in fact these
kind of satanic tropes
are this strange dark mirror that
ultimately will reflect back
to god even if it's not in their will to
do that even if
they're doing it despite themselves it
ends up bringing back
the image of god even you know because
like you said the negation
can't have doesn't have can exist
it it always is pointing to its in the
and
the the the parasite needs its host you
know you can't
the parasite can try to feed up itself
but at the in the end
it has to reaffirm the host or else it's
going to die itself can't live without
the host
yeah and so there's no sort of
secular there's no sort of neutral
there's no sort of
bare bones well we've stripped away all
of the
you know or banished any kind of meaning
or spiritual significance to
this place person thing idea
right it's yeah it would cease to exist
it would have to just cease completely
cease to
exist for you to banish any form of of
sacred from
from a person or from anything because
it's that's the actual shape of how it
exists
is the the actual pattern of how it's
there and how you even notice it
out of the millions of things you you
don't notice you know it's
because it has a it has the same pattern
as the this little holy place you know
where you see things come together and
are in communion
uh you know in communion into something
so yeah and that's been probably the
hardest nut to crack
on lord of spirits has been
people's idea that existing means you
know
this mug exists because i can bang on it
you know like
right it has physicality to it that
means it's exist as opposed to existence
meaning
it has an order and a form
and so the opposite being chaos not
an imaginary void or whatever it is that
they think
yeah but i think you know i think i
think we're getting there
i mean i feel it i i can see that you
know the people that are close at least
to the to
your podcast the people that are close
to what i'm doing i can see that they
get it like i can see they understand
it but for sure it's somebody who comes
in kind of just
cold on these ideas obviously sometimes
they
i've had people tell me that i don't
know why but they've said that
for two years they listened to what i
was saying and didn't understand what i
was talking about
and then i don't know why they would
continue to listen to it dude that's the
curious part but then they said oh
finally i get what you're talking about
and i'm like well good i guess i maybe
i'm not explaining it well enough then
but
it's a difficult thing because we're
basically breaking a pattern of
of thinking like that that has been
prevalent for 100 years more so
yeah yeah i mean literally the the words
uh that that get translated as
nothingness or non-existence in english
usually in greek
is uh tomion right which
literally means that which isn't
being being is a verb there it's a
participle
so it's that which is not doing the
action of being or existing
so when people try to push back on me
and say well no look see there's
nothingness in the ancient world i say
okay what's
that what's the pronoun referring to
right because a pronoun has a referent
right
yeah and so that referent is
chaos right that referendum or prime
matter or pure becoming
depending on your ancient philosopher
however you want to
yeah the only nothing you could say the
only nothing in
in this is going to sound weird to
people but the only nothing is god in
the sense of that he's not a thing
right and so the object of the world
right and so when we say that god
created out of nothing we don't mean
that there was this nothing
that was there that god created out of
it just means that
that that that god is the origin
of all and the origin of chaos even like
the origin of all possibility
and of all actuality is in this infinite
no thing no beyond being whatever you
you know
going up straight into uh dionysus
theopa guy you know trying to
find words for things that can't be
named but but that's really the only
thing that is really nothing in the in
the
the strict stance let's say i i like the
way saint john chrysostom phrases it in
his anaphora
because he talks about god bringing all
things
bearing or carrying the moving all
things
from that which is not being
to being hmm so then you really have
this idea of moving from potentiality
into actuality
right and of course right of causation
right yeah and putting and being the one
who
puts things in order yeah that makes a
lot that makes definitely makes a lot of
sense in terms of understanding
but i i really see that i i think we're
getting there not only do i think we're
getting there i think
that at this point i think that they're
that this is the future like there's no
other way
you know and and that this type of this
type of thinking and the people that are
going to be able to
to kind of use it how can i say this
that the fruits that are going to come
out of this you know they they're going
to be the ones that will be able to
answer
the madness of the of the post-modern
world because using the old arguments
doesn't work anymore there's no room for
them
yeah the the the whole hubris
of modernism the whole positivist
project looks laughable now
but like no i could i could send if you
read the preface
to hodges systematic theology from old
princeton in the 19th century
you would laugh out loud where he's
talking about how theology is a science
and the biblical text gives us the data
and so we just need to extract the data
from the
biblical text and follow good
sound deductive logic and then the
truths of theology are just as
objective as the law of gravity right i
mean it's laughable
like no one christian pagan atheist
anyone
can buy that now right and
at the same time post-modernism has
proved completely
unable to get past nihilism yeah no
matter how much they try
yeah and so the only
other option is to try to go back
to some of what we set aside
in those pursuits in the first place
yeah and reinvigorate them because
you know the idea for example like
i just want to say like you're you're
i've been wanting to talk about
first enoch for you know for a long time
and i've just been avoiding it
because of the problem of the angels in
humans and because i know that that was
such a hangout for
hang up for people and i i was like okay
i'm not going to talk about it
but that book offers so many solutions
to our problems even in terms of
the idea of technology coming and
technology and you know
power to act in the world coming from
these demonic forces and how it
basically led to
corruption moral corruption but also
physical corruption and then
leading to the flood i'm like this is
what's going on around you right now i
mean if we could have that
access to that tradition again and the
uh
the
the solution that you give which is the
nephilim ritual which is that this was
a ritualized practice uh and that it was
done through humans but through this
ritual
that still exists today in japan and
still exists
and existed you know you know continue
to exist in the world
it just solves all the problems and all
of a sudden the book of enoch doesn't
like it can't bother anybody anymore
because even the reason why it bothered
the later fathers is solved now like you
don't even
you don't have to worry about that
anymore yeah
yeah and and it becomes and we talked
about this on the show a little but it
becomes clear when you
read those fathers and you have to be
very clear what they were bothered by
they they weren't bothered by the idea
of sexual congress between spiritual
beings and humans because
like saint augustine who was one of the
great opponents
of that view probably the greatest
in terms of his influence uh believed in
incubi and succubi for example
so in other places he talks about them
it was the idea of reproduction
right yeah that they they would be able
to reproduce
but when you look at their arguments
like you look at saint john cashion's
arguments
and one of his key arguments is well if
that was happening then
and it was happening after the flood why
isn't it still happening now
and it's like well because you're living
in in you know 430
a.d and so there aren't any
pagans around anymore to do it but there
were people doing it in mesoamerica
and in japan you know china
yeah and there if you read like when you
read the hammer of witches
uh that's what it sounds like they're
talking about
yeah because they they talk about how
the women are having uh relationships
with demons
but they say they say you can't it's not
possible but
they just say and then they just say
it's just through secondary causes
they don't like them even it's like for
they're so they're so like
you know they're such thomas that they
don't need to explain it like we don't
have to explain
the secondary causes we just know it's
secondary causes you know it's like
it's it's the seed of other men that is
they say something like the seed of
other men which is
gathered by uh succubi uh
and then then are given to the incubus
which will then impregnate the woman
which
is also like okay you didn't explain
anything at least not like in the way we
think of explaining
by saying that but it's like i i i keep
how can i say this i keep joking that we
have versions of that now it's called
artificial insemination like that that
is actually
that process materially manifesting
itself
where you know you gather the seed of a
man and then you put it into
a woman she has a child from a man
that's not her husband and
i know that the guys who wrote the
hammered witches would have said
that's witchcraft like that's actual
witchcraft
it seemed like it was going on because
it's how they talk about it in like the
16th century
in in and they didn't have access to
these theories that at least
not that i know of right and and
our modern view of science has skewed a
lot of those
connections right but with going just
going back to the book of enoch
right they don't draw a distinction
between
like sorcery right knowing how to make
ambulance
right and do inscriptions that will ward
off evil
as know-how as technique as technique
right
and on one hand and metallurgy
right forging iron weapons yeah it's all
the same
it's all the same it's just it's using
meaning to affect the world like using
these essences to affect reality
right right and so we now have these
you know this schism between those but
they're the same
you know for it from that that approach
and also the same in the book of enoch
is the art of applying makeup and
perfumes and seducing people
that's right yeah there's that one of my
favorite
parts of that book is when it says
azazel taught them the art of metallurgy
and the art of of painting the the
eyelids
i was like that's it like in one
sentence it's amazing
well because i think it's also because
the the the thing they were using for
paint on the eyes were
were made of metal this idea of this
like metallic paint that they're putting
on which is perfect in terms of the
symbolism
as well but it's like that's the hope
the whole idea of the garments of skin
seduction is part of that
like seduction is part of this covering
of yourself
to hide yourself but then also to
increase your power let's say
and power of seduction or power to kill
someone is also
that if you use an artificial manner if
you use an artificial means to increase
your power
it doesn't matter what you're increasing
it towards it's it's the it's the same
it's the same uh process let's say um
yeah right right and that and so of
course we have the same thing
right in our world people using an
understanding of how the world works
whether that's on a physical material
level or a social level
you know or a spiritual level you know
psychological understanding sociological
unders
in order to accrue power to themselves
to control and dominate and you know i
mean that's who the giants are they're
tyrants
a witchcraft it's all winter
they're able to do that because they
have this knowledge you know
that that and that's how they're using
it and there's an interesting
there's this so there's this interesting
idea that it's like that hubris
is what leads to the flood and
like one of the interesting fascinating
narratives that i've been
seeing you know the kind of
environmental narrative that has been
popping up
it's very fascinating because there's
something of
enoch in the environmentalist narrative
and
you know even though i don't totally
ascribe to a lot of the tropes of the
environmentalist narrative
if you look at it it can help people
understand what it means
like what the judgment of god is you
know what it means that
god judges the world and destroys it
it's actually it's actually playing out
of the very processes
themselves it's not it's not like this
arbitrary god that just arbitrary judges
the world it's
it's kind of like the the things that
you do will
have repercussions and those
repercussions will be the judgment of
god on you it's not
arbitrary at all right and that's
um you know regardless of what anybody
thinks about climate change and the
science and all that stuff right that's
a scientific question
fine but the idea that our actions
and the way we relate to each other and
the world
affects and changes for the positive or
negative the world around
us at all levels
is well was clear to everyone in the
ancient world
and it should be clear it should be
cleared yeah but even that there's like
a no
there's a point of no return right
that's the thing that you see in the
flood is that a lot of people
um a lot of people don't like the flood
idea because they think
you know how is it that god could you
know could do that
because they can't imagine that there's
actually a point of no return
where the the the mechanisms that you've
laid out
are are your they they're rolling and
you can't stop it it's just going to
you can't you know it's like a ball
rolling down the hill you can say
well it's just rolling down the hill you
can't stop it anymore and
the environmental narrative has that in
it it's the idea that at some point you
reach a point of no return
and then it's it's over um but it can
help us like i said i don't i
don't totally ascribe to it for other
reasons but
i think that it can help people
understand what it means like what
what the flood narrative is and what it
means that uh god
can judge the world let's say yeah and
you see you see that tipping point
all through the scriptures um the the
the next book i have coming out that's a
process right now is about violence in
the old testament
and so it's dealing with a lot of this
stuff but you have this
imagery of a given people's cup of
iniquity
being full or not being full right or
the the land itself reaching this level
of pollution
right and the cries of the victims
you know coming before god and that
reaching a point where
now he has to act he can't allow right
he's trying to show mercy
to the wicked by not cutting them off
immediately
their wickedness but that reaches a
tipping point where
his love for the victims
he has to put a stop to evil at that
point
and you see that with the flood you see
that with the giant clans you see that
with
um when joshua comes in fights a giant
clan so you see that with
oh if you see that with israel itself
later on yeah even within israel that
that some aspect of israel gets
gets judged and gets you know is
basically falls apart
yeah it gets it gets past this tipping
point
um where where
the god's mercy toward
the victimizers gets overtaken by his
mercy toward their
future victims yeah so here's my big
question this is kind of like my big
question i think you probably i know
what you're gonna answer but i
think it's important uh so this this
one of the things that i see you're
doing and and that i really
appreciate is i would call it restoring
the
the mythology of christianity which some
people are going to think sounds
horrible but i know you you know
what i mean when i say that
and and my question is do you think that
we can live like we can live in that
story again you think it's possible for
modern people
to to to live once again in that that
kind of grand story
yes that's the short answer yes i would
like you to elaborate
i will instead answer it
[Laughter]
so um this is gonna go a little deep
again
right but um and this gets into
some phenomenology but we've been
talking about this lately on lord of
spirits
so if people listen to that not gonna be
totally familiar with that but
the world we live in right our actual
umvelt as a person um
is constructed by the interaction
of reality which actually exists right
interacting with our human consciousness
uh and um
it's always been true always will be
true as long as humans are humans
right
but what we've mainly lost
even in most of christianity that's
become very materialist
what we've mostly lost is that there's
a third input there which
is god not just the spiritual realm in
general but
god the divine energies god himself
acting in the world and
uh that's perceived by
we're gonna do a future episode of the
lord of spirits talking about the news
but
we have a perceptive organ yeah
to perceive that and to quote unquote
here or quote unquote see
that that's we've closed off
mostly on purpose and
that's why we've lost that sense
so it's a question of sort of
reawakening that
so that we're correspo we're interacting
with
all of reality and with the
the full scope of the world but this is
somebody asked in the lord of spirits
discussion group on uh
facebook a while back um
if anybody they talked about an
experience they had and asked if anybody
else had had
an experience in their life with the
grace of god just a direct encounter
with the grace of god
and my response to that would be have
you ever had an experience in your life
that wasn't a direct encounter with the
grace of god
right and because
the divine energies god's work pervades
all of creation
right subject and object right yeah it's
our incapacity to actually
to to see it because it's there all the
time yeah right and we experience it
unaware and we're perfectly capable of
experiencing things unaware we
experience oxygen
unaware all the time yeah right i'm not
aware of the atmosphere surrounding me
right i'm not aware of this but um
it's it's there and we're unaware of it
and unacknowledging of it
and because of that we don't understand
anything
right it's not that we understand the
material element of reality really well
and don't understand the other
because we don't understand the other we
don't understand the material
either yeah it doesn't make any sense
either
um because we're missing this other
people but so that's
that's what it's about and when that
comes alive
um that's when you start to
live that way and it's something that
happens
it dribs and drabs and drips and drops
you don't like one day
like all of a sudden wake up and be like
okay i'm going to now
i i see the light i see the divine light
everywhere yes
like that isn't that hasn't happened but
it hasn't happened to me if yeah that's
for sure
not yet little bits and bobs right
little drips and drinks exactly
the way that person who posted that in
the group experiences
they had a moment of that right they had
a moment of that
and it's it's giving that the space to
grow
and but we tend to banish it yeah when
it does happen we tend to push it away
and explain it away
and we're scared of it we banish it or
some of us go the opposite direction
pursue it in all the wrong ways right
through psychedelic drugs
through right whatever yeah it's right
now
this is very right now there's it's a
very popular thing that's going on the
whole psychedelics is
coming back in a frightening way so yeah
right because
that's i mean uh if you want to find
sort of technique again sort of the the
method
for the noose for opening the eye of the
noose and all this
hey read some hindu literature
they've got all about it um
but i don't know if i'd go down that
route because you know we've seen with
the giants
at all what technique does when it's
applied in the wrong context yeah and
just
it's not fun the whole psychedelic
things is hilarious because
a lot of people that are coming to me
talking about it they they have a weird
they have a more kind of traditional
vision or kind of a traditionalist
idea let's say you know even if times
are not totally christian
but you know this the psychedelics came
out in the 60s guys
it's the psychedelics are part of the
reason why we're here
like we're in this this crazy world
because of the psychedelics
and so now bringing them back isn't
necessarily going to bring us in a
better spot
than than what happened in the 60s at
least i don't think so
there's not like there's more capacity
to discern
now than there was in the 1960s
right and and
artificially inducing a state or
experience
does not give you the ability to
understand and assimilate and process
and find meaning in that experience
right it just gives you an experience
and that experience can then go very
badly
right and if you need an example other
than psychedelics for that just look at
sexuality
yeah right we have all kinds of
artificial technological means now to
induce
sexual ecstasy and a sexual experience
but people who go down that path end up
with a sexuality that's
very disoriented and and bent
and confused and
not healthy you know for them or anyone
else right and it becomes very hard to
come back from that
yeah not impossible with the grace of
god but very difficult to come back
and so long answer is that you you think
that it is
like i'd say for the post-modern world
right now in north america
um that we have the capacity to re
to to live once again in this story
let's say the story
uh this grand story that that you're
presenting in lord of spirits
i think so but yeah to make a beginning
of it
yeah to make a beginning of it um
yeah yeah and
there's what i was i was just talking to
somebody about this today
one of the real problems we face frankly
and
i'm not going to get into politics
especially not canadian politics
but but that is one of the problems we
face
because there's this whole territory of
our our
communal life and our social life
that's been bracketed off now as oh
that's politics
you have to stay out of there you can't
go
into there that's not connected to
anything else and nothing else is
connected to that
and they've kind of made it sacrosanct
and
eventually it's not going to be able to
be right because
because eventually it's not enough to
just
reshape my personal life
eventually i've got to reshape my family
life yeah
and then community life and i mean it's
gonna hopefully
progress out from my personal life right
that's the place that it starts
yeah but down the road we're gonna smack
into that fence around politics
and there's gonna be a kind of a
reckoning where we're going to have to
things are eventually going to have to
kind of dismantle
in that arena to yeah because it's
happening
one of the things that one of the things
that post modernism do
is doing is it's breaking down the
material
stability let's say the materialists
they at least had some kind of stability
they they didn't have access to the
angels
and they didn't have access to the
demons let's say so they were protected
from
a little bit protected from one side but
also protected from the other
and so as post-modernism kind of breaks
down that
solidity you know a lot of dark stuff is
seeping in
and so the the you know the politics
themselves are already being
let's say taken up by these weird
demonic
forces and you can see it it actually
appears to you right you see
possessed people like i don't know
literally possessed but at least
you know they're they're they're
semi-possessed at least they're being
ridden by demon however you want to say
it
um and so it's happening and it has a
weird coherence to it
like a kind of weird uh dark coherence
to what's going on
and so and so i think like you said that
at some point we also need to be able to
understand that
as those that are looking to have
discernment in this
breakdown and hopefully look up and look
towards god
and see how all this can come together
you know it's it's gonna it's gonna have
to face that
we're gonna come face to face with that
uh at some point too
yeah there there's there's a very good
book
called uh earthly powers that's talking
about
uh 19th century
european politics on the european
continent
and it shows how in terms of iconography
the civil iconography
in terms of patriotic songs in terms of
you know the structures of government
how all of the things that were
associated with religion
before the french revolution yeah all
the iconography all the music
all the everything gets transferred to
political parties
and political napoleon you know
political yeah yeah
and personalities and
i don't want to be a total downer but
that line of development gave us world
war one and two
that's right and bolshevism
and stalinism that's where that leads
and
i think the same thing is now happening
in north america
we're seeing the iconography that used
to be attached
to albeit the protestant puritan kind of
american church
right now getting transferred into
[Music]
politics and and and uh
you know political more political
morality you know
that's yeah the whole
last year was uh was just a symphony of
insane religious upheaval like there was
just all this religious imagery
flooding back into the world um and uh
and and it's scary like it's not it it
doesn't look good it doesn't
it doesn't have it it doesn't have the
transformative
uh power you know that christianity does
because
the likes we're seeing the scapegoat
mechanism kind of
get brought into the world um
and you know christ gave us the solution
to that
and which is self will which is self
sacrifice but now that's not what's
going on
there once again is this this demonizing
of of
of groups and this and it's done in a in
a very strange sacred
way using this imagery that is very
religious and so
yeah it doesn't it looks like we're
going back to paganism that's what it
looks like
yeah there's i was i was recently
listening to some comments from believe
it or not a uh
marxist university professor who was
talking about
what he called the great awokening uh
which is itself religious language yeah
that's
um but talking about the problem with
sort of woke liberalism
and he said you know it's just too
protestant for me
that they're all out there arguing about
who's going to heaven and who's going to
hell
yeah he's like i'm trying to do politics
but that's those but it reveals to us
what really drives these things like it
reveals to us
what that the the passions that are
behind
or the desires that the the hidden
desires that are behind these political
actions are actually spiritual
you know and they're distorted and
they're contorted but you know
if he thinks that it was any different
during the bolshevik revolution oh no no
what do you think was going on back
there it was exactly
it was very religious the way that i
mean this deification of lenin and
uh you know like the embalming of his
body all of this like what do you think
is going on this is not
politics absolutely but the
the you know puritanism is always sort
of associated with
you know the the american right you know
that
that they're they're not only that
they're puritanical but that they see
themselves as sort of
pure in terms of the elect you know
they're the good ones they're the good
people
and there's these other sinners but now
we've got the exact same thing on the
other side
you know where we've got women like
marching on washington
dressed as puritans in an ironic way
to tell men they need to act more like
puritans in an unironic way
yeah it's it's
yeah it's getting crazy out there and
and yeah and the
the whole cancel thing uh
all of that is just like it's exactly
this kind of excommunication like there
really is just an excommunication
uh but it's like almost like a
democratic excommunication
very strange racism in the greek sense
right we all write the name of the
person and we throw them out of the city
that's what's going on that's exactly
what's happening and so we really are
seeing a kind of flooding in of paganism
and paganist
pagan structures and pagan gods i would
even say
and so so we've got work to do
you know
but but but
now that i've had a negative nancy all
right let's get a positive answer finish
with the positive thing here
to be positive i guess positive p i
don't know um
what one of the things i grew up in
southern california
which was sort of ahead of the curve on
this so if somebody there was a pagan
they had a big license plate saying they
were a pagan
they said proud pagan right yeah and if
somebody was an atheist they were an
atheist
or someone right you know everybody was
pretty clear on on
who they were and i went to co under my
undergraduate in east texas
which is very different culture right
there everybody went to church
right the the the county that school was
in was the only county
in east texas that was not a dry county
it's the only place you could get
liquor yeah so the county was just
packed with bars
and strip clubs right but
all the strippers were in church on
sunday morning right like
everybody went to when you met people in
this town
they said that they asked you what
church you went to
that was like the second question yeah
what's your name and what church do you
go to what church do you go to
because that i mean that was how class
divisions worked that was how
you know i mean that so it was all what
church do you go to
and the people there were no more
committed to the christian faith
than the pagans and atheists and stuff i
grew up with in california
right they were just fooling themselves
and sort of
being performatively christian sort of
publicly
so as that breaks down everywhere i
think we're actually in a better
position because at least we all know
where we stand
yeah we there's no advantage like the
the advantage of
being a christian is going away and is
it's gone pretty much and so
it's it's so it's it's harder well
there's probably still some but
it's they're less they're very in
certain places but
let's say that it doesn't have the same
the same effect as it used to and so
like you said
then it definitely going to wean out a
lot of the
the people that weren't that weren't
serious about about why they were there
and what they were doing so
and that that opens up the possibility
of actually having real conversations
with those people
because if you approach someone who's in
this bad place in their life
and lost but they insist that they're a
good christian and believe in jesus
right i'm very limited in what i could
say to them
you know and as an orthodox priest
they're gonna you know
think i'm roman catholic first of all
and they're gonna
critique you know try and do some kind
of
surface critique of my theology and just
disregard me
yeah you know um
whereas if someone knows you know
no i am lacking something spiritually
maybe i want it maybe i don't but
that kind of person in that kind of
position is much more open to hearing
what other people have to say
yeah you know yeah i've seen a strange
and it'll be interesting to see like i'm
being more involved now here in quebec
i'm trying at least
it's like almost like a therapy for me
um
with these french canadians and so uh
i've seen the younger generation they
they actually don't know anything about
christianity
the the the like the people in their 20s
like late teens and 20s
they don't know anything and so they're
actually not even hostile towards it
they're just like i don't know what this
is like uh what is this what is your
thing uh and so it actually
it's like a clear slate that you can
speak into um
and uh yeah so it'd be interesting to
see how that how that's gonna how that's
gonna play out it definitely
it's not it's not it's not a battle it's
not the same kind of battle it's just a
more like real conversations yeah yeah
and we have to we have to approach it
that way too
uh and not make assumptions about who
people are and where they're at and what
they think
yeah exactly i've had some fascinating
conversations with pagans since we
started lord of spirits
because when you start out by saying
like
no i believe all those gods exist
yeah yeah that's been my move for like
several years when people say
you know a christian is just someone who
believes in like one
just you know like one what did they say
like one uh less god or whatever like
i'm like what are you talking about i
believe in all the gods like
i've always believed in all the guts and
so so let's have another discussion
because that one's definitely not going
to work on me
yeah yeah and sometimes they just look
at me in disbelief and i'm like no
that's what christianity is and i talked
to them about theosis and stuff and
they're like wait what you know
yeah exactly so so last question i guess
before we go
um so what are you hoping for for the
book like what are you hoping
the discussion would what it will bring
about you know the effect that it'll
have i'm
i'd like to know how you see it being
how you hope it's going to be received
yeah well i started out saying it's a
bunch of different things
and that's the main reason i say that is
that
i think or i'm hoping that that there'll
be a bunch of different
gaps that it will fill right
i sort of deliberately structured it as
a biblical theology and i've already
gotten feedback from some people because
ancient faith released the table of
contents
as part of a sample earlier i've gotten
feedback for example from a lot of
protestants who are sort of interested
in biblical theology
like they look at the table of contents
and they're like
okay this is the structure is familiar
to them
right the layout is familiar to them and
so they're interested in what the
contents are going to be
yeah and it it really it's
it's i was surprised because i wasn't
expecting when i got it i wasn't
expecting it to be like a kind of
apologetics book but
mostly in a way that's what it is in
like a biblical theology but done
trying to help people see people who are
interested in biblical theology
understand what it means like what it
means in terms of
the tradition that was actually there in
the early centuries that you discounted
and and so it's like you're studying
this on this side you're ignoring this
on this side
now let's see if we can connect them
together and then all of a sudden a lot
of things are going to make sense to you
like one of the best things in the book
i don't know if you want to spoil it but
you give the best ex you give the best
explanation for the baptism
for the dead that i've ever heard and
when you when i read it i thought i'm
such an
idiot for not having thought that before
it was just so obvious
i know if you're willing to spoil that
for for the people watching
yeah well i i kind of go in i get kind
of granular with the greek
on that one um and and there's sort of a
bunch of
of pieces to it in terms of the way it's
but
again i'll try and do a shorter version
that
that um essentially this is
this is talking about a practice that we
still do today
in the orthodox church which was at that
time in the first century
someone being baptized and taking the
name
of a martyr right who had gone before
within the understanding in the
greco-roman world
of patronage and of how when you take
someone's name your actions bring honor
right to to that person it makes so much
sense because all the other explanations
don't ever satisfy they just never
satisfied me
you know it's like no matter how people
tried to explain it to me i was
sometimes they would say well they did
it but but it doesn't it's not saying we
should do that
all this kind of weird explanation and
this the idea that you're baptized
for in the name of someone basically the
way that we do it now
it makes so much sense and and and it
explains
the origin of a practice that is like
you said is is just totally common in in
christianity and has been from from the
earliest stages when we hear
of people being baptized and taking a
new name and then we have the idea of
naming a child at their baptism all of
this
makes so much sense when you understand
it uh when so so it just to me that that
was like
it's so such a small thing but it can
help people see the type of
argumentation that you're giving
which is saying if you look at even at
the liturgical practice of the church
later on
it actually helps you understand it's
like have second temple type thinking
how the liturgical type uh type uh world
that we live in
and take those two look at the new
testament again
and all of a sudden so many things make
sense that you didn't understand before
and so like i don't think you're doing
many things like if i could say the one
thing that you're doing i think that
that's what you're doing
and it's a and it and it's a it's a
wonderful for people that are interested
in the bible it offers these wonderful
keys that you didn't
think were there before so yeah and i
think that's a good example
too because it shows a place where it's
our it's our modern view that gets in
the way
because the ancient view of identity
is that you know sort of like ogres and
shrek right there's layers
that your identity is is the composite
of these light right your family
right who your father is in particular
but your family
your community the city where you're
from i mean how many people in the
ancient world
their quote unquote last name is
actually the city they're from yeah
right that's part of their identity the
place where where they're from
the place where they live the community
they're a part of their
trade right right
all of these factors are layered and
that's your identity the modern sense of
the individual
is the inversion of that right yeah your
identity is the negation of all those
things and you can say that you don't
have to go to shrek
family we can just go to the to the to
the tabernacle like the temple is made
that way
right the the garden of eden the temple
all of these
are that's exactly what what is is
happening and
the idea that we are made in the image
of the macrocosm like that we are
microcosms in the in the image you know
the temple can help us see
how we're made that's how we have the
same structure as the temple that's why
we talk about
circumcision of the heart that's why we
talk about going into the heart or even
protestants talk about
you know like you know uh having jesus
in your heart
it's like all of that is is because
you're made like the temple and this
idea of identity
as these layers is actually what makes
the world coherent
or else we have these atomized realities
that are not interconnected so
right and and that's and if we're if
we're going to be wrapping up here
right this is another place for hope
right because
if you look at your average human life
right when you're a child your identity
is kind of given to you
right you're born into a family you're
born in a place you're born into a
community
you get brought to a church or other
place of worship
without choosing right you know all of
those things all those layers are placed
upon you and given to you and that's
your identity
then when you become an adolescent you
rebel against all that
right you become very modern and
individualistic right
i'm going to be my own person i'm going
to be who i am not you dad not you
community not your church right but then
when you become an adult
right you reappropriate all those things
that were given to you as a child
and really make them your own and they
really become your identity
so if that's what we can do collectively
as a people
right as an american orthodox church
as as people if we can go back and
reappropriate
some of that that was given to us when
we were young get past the rebellion
right then we can have that identity
again and have it for real
yeah in a real integrated way
and there's a kind of maturity in the
new way that we perceive it
you know not in the naivete that we had
as children which was fine at the time
but as adults you know coming at it
through this different way of seeing the
world
all of a sudden there's a maturity we
can bring to these to the story to this
to this reality um and it like you said
it's more integrated so
thank you thank you for the book i want
to tell everybody so get the religion
of the apostles it's out now we want to
we want it to be on the new york times
best seller list so
let's do this everybody i have student
loans
yeah i've seen lots of pay all right
thank you father stephen and thank you
for a load of spirits uh you know
everything you're doing
i'm really excited about the future and
what it what it brings
um you know i really do feel i really do
feel like i
i i have this kind of extended team
members that that were all kind of
working
in the similar directions and working
towards similar things and so um
so it's great i i don't feel alone
it's a cinematic universe there you go
there you go all right thank you father
thank you